the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok
ah I hope you all had a good break and
came back from San Francisco on Sunday
so last time we talked about a board
spun transfer equation and we we made a
drastic approximation that's a
relaxation time approximation so using
this relaxation time approximation the
original board portsmen transport
equation on the right hand side it was a
scattering term if you recall we said
that it's elastic line integrals right
because let's say when we have to party
or collide with each other we have the
sum up all the possibilities for that
collision by using the relaxation time
approximation we say all those
collisions you wouldn't really drive the
system back to equilibrium F 0 so that F
0 D is the equilibrant distribution
function and we also commented actually
this is not really strict let's say this
is of course its approximation there
many waist is not correct and later on
you will see that in fact this
approximation will not give you the
right the pronto number when you
calculate the fluid properties and for
relaxation time we discuss different
scattering mechanisms for example fallen
fallen ski
turn electron phonon scattering and
scattering by impurities and we say if I
have multiple scattering mechanisms I
use the Matheson rule where the total
relaxation time is the inverse of all
the scattering processes involved in the
transport and I want to also make the
additional comment that say even though
you can solve the Boltzmann equation in
this format under relaxation time
approximation and often the largest
uncertainty come from this relaxation
time we do not have a good way to
calculate relaxation time we say you go
to quantum mechanical fermi see golden
rule to calculate so that way you have
to go to quantum mechanics and in fact
that's the active research topic for
example immediately I'll jump into
thermal conductivity prediction a photon
thermal conductivity prediction and a
recent a large step that's made in this
field is the ability to actually use the
density function theory to calculate
this relaxation time and using this
relaxation time as a feed into the
boards my equation so you can now show
us a computer the property like a
thermal conductivity of the materials so
this is where we were last time and
today we're going to solve this board my
equation in the classical limit where if
you recording the second lecture we went
through a very approximate derivation of
the Fourier law of heat conduction and
also Ohm's law and you had a homework on
ficks law so all those laws see we did
as a very say
evening but now we can use this equation
read arrival so when we went through a
really long cycle to come back to our
second lecture and I'm going to show you
today hopefully I'll cover fit as a
Fourier law will cover loading shear
stress law and it will cover all small
okay
so let's first say look at the general
solution see approximate so boards my
transport equation is ready
approximation but when I let you solve
it I was all under diffusion
approximation so I will do a small
perturbation method and the slow of the
Boltzmann equation together diffusion
laws so see let's say diffusion
approximation again you hear I'm making
approximation again you can see what you
learn had not of approximation made okay
and say so what I mean diffusion
approximation is when I try to solve the
Boltzmann equation under proddy a
recision time approximation I see the
you can say I say they use a
perturbation method the F deviates from
F 0 only slightly so the difference
gives me G and this G is orders of
magnitude smaller than f zero right you
can do more rigorous maths and they
using versus a asymptotic method but
this is the basic assumption making is G
is much smaller than F and the F 0
itself and this also say because of this
F equals to F 0 plus G so I'm going to
substitute it into the Boltzmann
equation and I have DF 0 DP plus DG
dt+ way and just make one more comment
this way now in the boards my equation
should be considered this is the group
velocity of the particle that's the
particular C carry energy at this
velocity so this way dot F 0 and the way
dot G and this is our right remember F
itself is a function of time it's a
function of a space X Y Z is also
functional momentum p XP r py PZ right
it's a quantity one particle
distribution function in the phase space
and on the second term I have F now this
is the gradient in the Momentum's
component and the F dot gradient P G
equals G last all right okay so I'm
seeking the first order solution
G is much smaller than F and F 0 so the
approximation which you can do more like
I said a better mess but basically on
the left hand side or this higher order
gradient term on G drops out under my
approximation okay
and we later on we'll come back to this
reduce cuss when this is not valid right
and that's in fact the kind of lecture
last chapter when we discuss classic or
size effects so those drops out and let
me further for the constitutive equation
like a for-real or let me drop say also
drop the DF 0 DT in fact even if
a.charat your drop out ok because the f
0 is a sigma
trig function so let me just say do
steady-state this this is another you
censure so I can drop the time term and
then with this I have G minus at all and
the way dot are F 0 plus F dot P F 0
right and so I am more used to F itself
so I can go back to add back the F 0 so
f 0 F equals f 0 x plus G so I have our
F 0 plus F dot P F 0 okay so this is my
solution
for the distribution function f when I
have the lid area later on you will see
this will be reflected in terms of
temperature gradient velocity gradient
or electrical field these are all
including in this gradient firm terms ok
so this is my approximation I have the
solution I'm going to use this to get my
flux when I want to calculate heat
transfer I'm interested in heat flux
when I want to calculate charge and
really see the current I'm interested
current flux and all are in terms of
this stress shear stress I'm interested
in the momentum flux so force energy and
say charge right so let's do first the
Fourier law
I'm going to use full-on as my prototype
in deriving the Fourier law and in this
case like to look at the fallout heat
conduction right and I have a medium and
with the temperature gradient let us say
this is Z direction and this is the day
T is a function of Z right
one-dimensional make it easy you can do
I say arbitrary a city 3d easily
extension so in this case my local F
because each Z point there is a
temperature and the F 0 right the
corresponding equilibrium distribution
is the boson Einstein distribution right
so let's write down the boson Einstein
distribution is exponential h-bar Omega
K be t minus 1 right so you can see F F
we said it is a function one per your
distribution function in phase space
this is a equilibria in the case of
equilibrium it's a function of Omega the
energy not just another momentum right
it's a it depends on energy and depends
on temperature temperature is a function
of Z so when I do this spatial gradient
are the DF 0 the spatial gradient is
rear DF 0 TZ + VZ this term I do not
have force external force acting fonna
right and so this term drop out so now
I'm going to do my F equals to F 0
- at all VZ DF 0 TZ is a DT if I use the
chain rule is DT DZ right okay now I
have F as a function now you can say if
there is itself is the isotropic because
there's a doesn't depend Direction H
Omega but the F is a non isotropic
because this velocity is a has direction
right so if I have a photon actually in
solid go all the ration it's a random
motion a question now it's a bias random
motion because there is a temperature
gradient right so hold on with the group
velocity in this direction then it's Z
component is the weight times cosine
theta right now F itself has direction
and a by say F 0 is isotropic now I'm
going to calculate heat flux so heat
flux is this is the distribution of one
specific quantum state ok one part of
your distribution function at a specific
quantum state with certain momentum
pxpypz is V X V Y VZ ok so if you recall
when I do specific heat I sum up all
quantum state states so I'm doing going
to do the same I'm going to do this
summation of K X K Y KZ I'm doing
momentum space now right they Q is a
function in real space so I sum over all
possible quantum states they feel the
momentum space kxk by different momentum
and then each mold I have h-bar Omega
that's the energy right that's a one
photon energy and I have this manifold
on in that quantum state and if I have
polarization I add a polarization
because if you think about what we learn
before unfold on dispersion this is
specifically the Russian I have say
transfers for long longitudinal
Cristofori up two photons right so I
have to sum up over all those folder
modes and the each mode I have my
solution on how many photons at that
specific mode given this local
temperature T and that this will now
give me flux if I divide by volume you
will get the flux oh sorry I have the
this is the energy right if you do
specifically f0 this is your energy
density then I have to do the fluxes of
velocity the movement at the Y Z so it's
a V Z that's the component in the Z
direction that's the net flux in the Z
direction okay
so once you know how to write this term
from here next day is all see you have
your solution f is converting this
summation into integration that's what
we did before for density of states
right however when we do the density of
states we didn't care about directions
and this is I this in the in we to flux
for transport I have to be careful on
direction okay I'll still used n sub
States butter with the twist so let's go
to write down those other terms I'm
going to convert so Q I look at that
summation
is a discrete number you recall right if
I want to convert it into integration I
say dkx that's a lens in the K X
direction but see each mode that this
spacing is a two pi divided by L right
so the number of points is a 2 PI over L
X if I have lens D K X so by using this
diecut that I convert this sum over K X
how many points into the integration so
I have K X integration
I have d KY and two PI over L Y decays a
2 PI over L Z in the past I just use the
same arrow you can doesn't matter
because at the end of volume console LX
ly LZ cancel right so I have my three
integrals this is now KX KY KZ and I
have to my some different polarization
different branches P and volume and the
rest is still H Omega fvz so I have
h-bar Omega V Z F is the F 0 minus top
VZ TF 0 DT DT DZ I'm just copying what I
have in this expression here right so
the K is converting the summation into
integration and now I have d KX d KY d
kz I have a pike - PI cubic and the weak
hand so so let me
I'm going to skip one one step because
there are too many
of this kind of writing now you have the
choice how to do this integration right
in the past when we do specific heat so
it is easier to convert this into
integration over energy right because
the f0 here is a function of Omega so
you you you say okay either I integrate
the over Omega or I integrate over d KX
DK by DK is a PI say if before it was a
pretty symmetric when I do energy and
here I have the problem of a is a
function of the rationality this is a
directioner so the rationality in the
phase space because this is random group
velocity of the particles right so how I
do this integration d KX DK by DK z for
this specific problem I'm going to
convert this into a spherical coordinate
okay so dictated by Daka
this one is if I do a spherical
coordinate now see I cannot do just a 4
PI K squared DK because I have the
rational dependence so I have to do
integrate so this is my theta and the in
the XY kxky plan I have an angle Phi
right spiracle coordinate so if I write
DK x DK by DK z in spherical coordinate
I get a sine theta D theta K square like
R square sine theta D theta D Phi D K dr
that's my that's my d KX d KY d kz why
do energy before I just simply already
integrated science II that is D theta
and D Phi that's give me a 4 pi
I can do that because here I have with
the rationality
in my integrand okay so now I do you can
say because I'm doing this Farrakhan in
like hey I can use because at the end I
still have to choose between K
integration roaming Omega integration
because the F itself is Omega right I
have the relation between different
value of K and Omega that's my
dispersion that's what we went through
before so the other the way to do it is
say DK you can write D K into P K P
Omega and D Omega and D K D Omega if you
use your dispersion K Square PK D Omega
and you can convert it everything back
into things up straight except the dens
up states before it's a 4 PI K square DK
right there's a full pipe but here
because I have to carry the angle so I
don't have that 4 pi so I have to be
there is a extra 4 PI in this conversion
so now I'm going to do a converter
rather than kxkykz integration limit I'm
going to do sigh so instead of Phi and K
Niemann Omega limit because here I'm
doing the Omega integration right so my
I have 0 2 Omega max that's whatever the
fallout dispersion of the material is
that's the maximum frequency you
integrate to and you will say the Phi
integration Phi here the kxky plan right
that's a 0 to 2pi okay so I have 0 to
2pi
that's defy and see how
what's the integration limit is Theta
zero to the other side is a PI so the
photon go in both the ration all
directions right so this latter
difference is a forward backward the
picture we have before in second lecture
is that I have any imaginary surface
photon go across that surface is forward
the difference the backwards give me the
left flux and here I'm doing that more
mathematically it's going all the
Russians so here I have zero to PI this
is my D Phi this is my D theta and this
will be my D Omega and the Resta is a
polarization 2 pi 2 pi 2 pi and the
oldest together gives me density of
states over 4 pi that 4 pi is because
like I'd mentioned before is a 4 PI K
squared DK I don't have C defy
integration okay so this and the rest of
the is the f0 minus tau VZ now wizzy if
I think about this a group velocity
right a projector into in the Z
direction is a V times cosine theta
right so I have tau V cosine theta Y
squared cosine theta square d f0 DT DT
DZ integration and I have sine theta
that's still there in my spherical
coordinate ok
so my theta sine theta and I have cosine
theta square f 0 itself with the
isotropic if you look at my F 0 is
isotropic ok now you can tell what's the
integration of first term f 0 term sine
theta integrated between 0 pi is the 1 0
F 0 term drops out F 0
oh I'm sorry ok because of whizzy whizzy
here yeah yeah f 0 so here I am
I miss this because when multiplying is
a ways away cosine theta
okay you're right otherwise it's a
cosine theta that's not 0 so right this
one we see multiplied in here I have a
square the first term is the V cosine
theta now integrate so cosine and see
that sine theta you integrate between 0
and pi D theta that's 1/2 cosine Z dot
square 0 because the 0 2 pi right so the
first term drops out and the second term
is a cosine theta square sine theta
integrate so that will give you one
third cosine theta cubed right C cosine
see that squared sine theta D theta that
one sir cosine theta cubic and then
integrate there's a negative sign in
front because sciency that go back to
negative cosine theta right so there's a
negative sign but a 0 2 pi that gave me
another - so there's another negative
sign so this one I actually gave me 3
halves to 2/3 2/3 I'm sorry
2/3 my fraction so Chinese the way they
reverse
okay so my what I have is 2/3 and tau V
Square D F 0 DT this is a this term drop
out this 2/3 I don't have Phi dependence
that's because of my density of states
in fact that I have made approximation
okay if you consider real Krister in
each direction you have to do then
substitute into this direction is also
different but in under my approximation
here 0 2 pi there's no other Phi
dependence so integration jug give me 2
pi right so I have another 2 pi and then
I have my density of states you Omega 4
PI and I'm going to put DT DZ that's a
constant pull out of the integration so
I have negative DT DZ 0 Omega max and D
Omega so this is a reader wishing of for
real law what you have here is the
thermal conductivity K right and the
heat flux is proportional to the
temperature gradient that comes from
this term and the proportionality
constant thermal conductivity we look at
it what do we have here
right - pi - that's a 4pi cons of this
4pi so it's a 1 sir so thermal
conductivity K is a one sir integration
0 to Omega max okay I have a DF DT prime
density upstairs oh I I should have H
Omega time that thermos should still be
there I come back here I miss here we
have H bar Omega that's this term here
okay so what I have H bar Omega times
density of states times D of T 0 DT is a
specific heat at that specific frequency
okay so this is a tau way square
specific heat as a the Omega each of
this term put depend on Omega right and
if we you go back to notes beforehand
the way veneer we said thermal
conductivity is specific heat velocity
mean free path that's what we did in
second lecture now we have a more
rigorous expression and each term now
depends on specific heat it depends on
frequency okay because it's so hard to
measure the mean free path right and I'm
not sure I give this problem work
problem before
one way is okay I take the measure space
thermal conductivity I take a measure
specific heat I take a speed of sound I
go to calculate the mean free path right
but there is a big difference between
this and this in terms of the details
the expression looks very similar if you
do this for silicon you get a 40
nanometer of the mean free path of
silicon
but this is a very very wrong
okay and people use that all the time
that's because if you look at this
photon dispersion right and group
velocity for contributors say very small
in the after photo you see object photon
group velocity speed of sound that's
here very large value right
but the real speed of sound as a group
or a t-4 a beautiful and very small so
they do not contribute much to the heat
conduction normally right but say if i
use the measure specific heat due to a
say at high temperature to contribute to
specific heat so I'm overestimating the
specific heat for this that carries heat
in the material secondly my group
velocity right if you say the speed of
sound is here the tangent but the group
velocity is changing to zero as it moves
along the dispersion right so again I'm
overcoming the velocity here so that
estimation gives you a very wrong result
and this like I said 40 nanometer and it
turns out that some of those photon has
a mean free path size one micron or you
and longer according to some of the
calculation we did is about in silicon
about half of the heat is carried by
following the mean free path of larger
than micron so that's the difference
there right when you start to count the
size the effect if you're if you use
from here is a 40 nanometer that's when
you start pay attention but if you go
from here you say okay
my understanding is I need to be very
bad when you get some micron range
different conclusion now if you look at
a typical curve of the thermal
conductivity you do this
integration right and you go to check
for most crystals the thermal
conductivity K versus temperature looks
like this Peltier okay that peak in
typical material happens around 20 or a
few tens of kelvins of course the change
with different materials okay at high
temperature this range is T to the nth
power and the theory is roughly T to the
first but this egg could be 1 to 1.5
range okay why is this Y at the high
temperature the thermal conductivity
drop with temperature if you check the
specific heat right if you recall for
solid specific heat at the final
temperature this is a patty DeLong
regime right
each mode contribute 1/2 KBT to energy
so specific it is constant because the T
derivative right and this regime is a t
cubic a low temperature and this here is
about T cubic and this here is about the
1 over T so what's happening there the
reason is you see here specific heat is
constant that means the energy is T
proportional to T okay and so when you
get to higher temperature Folan has
higher energy they move more violently
and this scatter move so in this regime
the relaxation time is the universe
proportional to energy so that's the
inverse proportional to temperature once
you go to this regime right as you cool
down they fall on scatter
on weekends so full-on photon scattering
do not happen say as you go to lower
temperature the mean-free perhaps
becomes long and the temporary in this
regime the mean free path could get to
the centimeters so that reaches a sample
size and the mean free path becomes
comparable to the sample size so it's a
constant and then the mean free path is
at all times way is a constant right
specific heat is appropriate to cubic
thermal conductivity is appropriate to
cubic and in this regime where fallen
fallen is an is weak what's really
important is impurities I mention they
say impurity scattering I get really
scattered fourth power and so if you for
example diamond which is the best
conductor right it turns out the most
material it has isotopes cuz diamond
city conch if you make them say we even
remove the isotope just to make it the
same atomic mass right isotope will get
in reach it you actually boost the
thermal conductivity by few times if you
can do that so you at the room
temperature there I don't know whether
that's settled but most likely even I
room temperature in most material like
silicon the diamond the isotope if you
purified the isotope actually you can
increase the neural connectivity so I
heard this a few years back probably 15
years back they were reported that
isotope will enrich silicon has a 60%
higher thermal conductivity and somebody
told me there was a big factory build
just to make the isotherm enrich the
silicon because he cannot go out from
from the chips I'm not sure whether they
were successful I didn't know not okay
so that's they are thermal conductivity
this is the example alpha
for yellow let's look at a flow problem
okay now I'm going to look at eluding
shear stress I have a flow right and the
simplest flow is a quit flow when I have
one plate fix the other places drag
parallel plates right and the velocity
say if this is my X so when I deal with
this this is my Y and I have in this
case when I have flow a significant
difference is now the average velocity
of the molecule is not zero right and so
it's not completely random and I have a
in the quad flow I have say a linear
velocity profile so any place I have
velocity U and the way of course is zero
for the quad flow and where u is a
function y right okay so in this case
are the F 0 what's the proper F zero and
you can go to so really the full boards
by equation by say a good approximation
this is a part of the croquet equation
is the F 0 now is a rather than f-zero
is the FD is a display sportsman and the
display sportsman is say remember the
postman factor is the MV square divided
by exponential energy divided by K T
right so energy is 1/2 MV square K BT
and say M
weh-weh is now the random velocity minus
the average velocity square Oh square
yeah doesn't matter okay so that's a
displace so way is the random velocity I
instance and you see the phase space
velocity and if you average away
you gotta see a velocity U so you
subtract that amount this is the
portsmen distribute display sportsman
and then say I have n the density in the
front and I do mean I forgot whether the
M is the denominator or numerator so M 2
pi K BT 3 halves and exponential so this
is a now I'm going to replace in my
relaxation time approximation replacing
F 0 by ft and this of course it means in
my current problem when I have a laminar
flow velocity is long zero velocity only
yolk I want to make my life easier so
what I have is the way X minus 0 square
plus the way Y square plus VZ square and
divided by 2 K BT the rest is the same
right so this is my F D and in this case
I'm going to replace F 0 by ft displace
for borscht Mac so this is F 0 F D this
is D FZ d now I have to do that
derivative right go back to my general
solution again say I don't have a force
acting on the molecule as an as I forget
about
petitioner force right pressure is
another force in my picture it's a
momentum okay
so I got this I have way D F D D R so R
remember in the here this U is a
function of y VX v vy VZ again my face
space verbal right they are independent
of X Y Z ok so I'm going to sum up we X
with Y Z with in my real term is here so
if I look at my F is then FD - how and
if I look at this weight up gradient the
RFD right what I have here I have say
because when I do this gradient with
respect to R I have DX which cancel
because the nothing depends on X I have
dy because the U is a function of Y
right
yo is a function of Y so I have the y
term so I should keep we why because the
way dot gridding right so what I have
here is a tall way Y and the DF 0 do and
x do dy this is my solution for the
Boltzmann equation casted under the
current problem right so I have my F my
lecture is a go to calculate the shear
stress in terms of the random the
distribution function f and the random
is a moment of space variables so what's
my
sure stress so why consider what's a
shear stress a high velocity flow say we
X the molecule is doing random motion I
have weave at vxvy right way by so the
shear stress is due to so in the Tau XY
what's my tau XY what's the shear stress
is due to the momentum exchange in the X
direction going across the plan Y right
the molecule go say para momentum MV X
and because the component sum of this
molecule going down sometime going up in
the Y direction so it's that exchange of
momentum in the Y direction across this
plan of the X momentum component gives
me the shear stress so when I do the
shear tau XY ok and I will have to
integrate now I'm not doing this script
because I'm using Maxwell distribution
we actually by the way they are treated
as a continuous variable so I have say
mass in flood to plus infinite
integration limit and my say shear
stress is MV X that's a momentary extra
ration the rate of charge in the Y
direction that's the molecule going
across the plan alright that will give
you the molecular level expression for
shear stress and the F DV X DV y DV Z
okay so now you substitute that your F
we have here and you do an integration
this is a good example where your
question again is do I converting into a
spherical coordinate to equip with the
original Cartesian we actually very busy
coordinate or you want to convert it
into way the energy right my square and
for this example it's much easier to
actually capable separate we actually
buy VZ and do your integration so this
is where I say once you're comfortable
starting point writing this down and the
rest is your own mass choice weather
which which you do so in fact if you a
jumper fuel step this term always drop
up the Ukrainian term always drop up
okay and you do your mass is the due to
symmetry okay it's an odd function when
you integrate from minus infinity to
plus infinite it cancels out physically
what it means is because the f is
isotropic in each direction is the same
okay and say so what if you look at the
solution F 0 let's say and F 0 actually
is say F is the F 0 solution
superimposed with a deviation term so
deviation term in the case of heat
conduction in the forward Direction is a
positive and backward Direction is a leg
here so it's actually this imbalance
this is your G we draw before that's
your G the difference between F and F 0
is this imbalance that's giving you the
left flux F 0 is self is equilibrium
they are equal going forward or going
backward
so there's no left flags now when I have
transport this one in the forward
direction more in the backward direction
s so the imbalance
give me the heat flux it give me month
on flux or this it's that's the the
physics behind this mathematical
expression so if I substitute this yen
and what you find out is I write it m 2
pi K BT 3 half and I'm going to put this
cow out I'm going to do constant
relaxation time okay and relaxing their
different model again for relaxation
time and mass in fluent plus infinite
and it turns out it's XA exposure M ways
a square to KBT and DV Z so I'm doing
each term separately and I have my other
two terms is I want to write this out
just to emphasize when you do different
problem you may have to choose your
different coordinate and that's your
freedom way Y square to KBT so this is
DV Y and then VZ mass infinite to plus
infinite and the M V X and minus ay yo
and this is a KBT that's what a comes
from of df0 do because the t FZ you have
this u in the exponent that's what I
have here and exponential minus M V X
maceió square and to KBT so DV X
and then say in also I have in the front
that you actually I have the dod why
that's the Newton shear stress no I put
it out because nothing
this attempt this is a real space
quantity it's not integrated over the
momentum space right so you can
integrate each one you can look at the
integration table if you don't know how
to do this integrations and you find out
at the end those are all constants so
what I have is really viscosity
expression so what I'm going to get out
of this all of this this one I'll have n
tau K BT
do dy this is my new insurance rational
do dy so what I have now expression but
we scarcely of the molecules is a and
tau KBT okay you can also do the thermal
conductivity right this is the momentum
you do your energy you get thermal
conductivity so thermal conductivity K
for gas molecule is you do your mass
you'll get the 2 v kb m kb t so it turns
out so times and how so it's related to
viscosity kb m mil so thermal
conductivity
is related to viscosity for gas
molecules okay and there are a lot of
this relation for example electricity
we're getting in so the electric
conductivity is related to thermal
conductivity that's all because of the
just a different in the course of the
board my equation and in this integral
what do you have here for example is
relaxation time and different the
molecular expression whether is a shear
stress py times my X which is energy
one-half MV square that you're doing the
integration of different functions
different the components carried by the
same say Marco any questions yes one
thing you really say in both my
nutritionist for very weak scattering
and by dr. David Wright here white it
can apply to the shear stress I didn't
say applied to liquid you're going to do
this only apply to gas gas molecules
okay you can't apply this to the liquid
okay
so it's a very good common layer and in
fact say the other comment I have is
that if you do with Class D thermal
conductivity ratio you can't get a
Prandtl number right what I have here
that's because the relaxation time
approximation if you go to now use a
plastic relaxation time approximation
you can actually get your point or
number right so in rarefied gas dynamics
in guess dynamics people have done this
so the footboards my inclusion and i
said made some comment before if you
want to find the partial resurgence own
boards my equation you go to gas
dynamics another work guild who they
mentioned that the Apollo project when
space
have to go through the other atmosphere
or you do neutron scattering people have
two neutrons scatter is also based on
boards my equation or you do full-time
transport based on boards my equation
and for for long and an electron there's
a later development so a lot of those
you can actually use those other see
development in other fields the
mathematics is the same the equation is
the same okay so now we have a heat
momentum let's do charge right electron
transport so I'm going back again to say
how I'm going to write F for electrons
and first recall in the case of
discussion the firmly part of the
electron will have Fermi Dirac
distribution which involves exposure
mark I say e minus mu KB T plus 1 right
so this gets a lot of a complication
conceptually it gets a lot of
complication of course your temperature
could be a function of space right mu we
typically call the chemical potential
right
and could also be a function space and
in fact if you recall how we define
mule right in the case of equilibrium
I see if I have example let's consider
only maybe a conduction band of a
semiconductor right conduction band
valence band let's say here is my energy
with vector right and the way we in the
under equilibrium you see the number of
charge is summation of will say spin of
all modes and each mode is the Fermi
Dirac distribution right this actually
gives us at a equilibrium at a certain
temperature using this I can find
because the given temperature I can
immerse the fan what's the chemical
potential if I know the number of charge
and see if I divide by per unit volume
and here I will have the Y at the volume
is divided to the other side right and
of course what we did before is this is
the Fermi Dirac this is density of
states this is the energy integration
this is what we did before one more step
because the density of states is a
constant have the email see you say
right you say is the bottom of the
conduction band tends up States that's I
said in the front is a relatively left
you factory mass you can now say that
the sit there and write yourself I'm not
writing I just say that's a constant
each material has its own constant right
and the point I want to make is okay if
I integrate Issei to infinite I'm just
to consider how many electrons in the
conduction band a fun day with this our
founder the F the chemical potential in
the expression but what I want to make
now is a very subtle this is this is a
really confusing I was reading a book at
this weekend this is a book on solar
sail and specifically there was a
paragraph by the also commenting on this
CC student don't understand the D that
you will not be able to measure
electrical field you'll measure
electrochemical potential and they say
well education has a problem right
that's the author's comment in the book
and so it's a very confusing for point I
hope you'll go through with me because
what I'm talking here is if I think
about this is a relate to the confusion
comes from you have electrons you have
holes you have positive charge you have
your letter e field you have chemical
potential would it measure okay and the
so here the electric field if I think
about the energy of electron is this is
the kinetic energy in the band one half
MV square and then there's a potential
energy EC that's the bottom of the band
right so I see okay energy is the EC
plus the ek kinetic energy because the
effective mass approximation right this
ek is one-half MV square right recall is
the UK H bar square K square 2 m in fact
your mass it's like my connecticut
effectively like in my kinetic energy
right
this energy is relative to EC and this
ye say is relative to whatever reference
this is where where's your reference in
my book I say there is an absolute
reference and in fact I say I don't
think of my book I even do other well
the absolute reference the best is just
to take the vacuum then everything is
actually below the vacuum so so the
vacuum is here you can say but then the
energy is negative of that so you were
more confusing okay let's let's just say
this is relative you say is right -
absolutely level right and that could be
a function of X then you see it could be
a function of X because different point
you could have a different potential
rather to that so so if I do this I
rewrite it in terms of ek because the
mule if we here is relative to any
absolute reference the mule is ready to
do the same reference okay and but now
I'm going to use the e equals EC plus UK
then you'll find out that what I have
here is I can do my coordinate I say
transfer rather than de I to D DK so I
will have ek because M is a is e K and
exponential ek minus e say mass mu minus
a divided by Kb T plus 1 so d EK I'm
just doing my coordinate transformation
rather than integrate from you say to
infinite I go from ek that's bottom to
infinite and the point I want to make is
mule master you see right we said a mule
is right to whatever absolute reference
this is right or to the same
reference so what I have is a mule
master you say is wherever my camp
si mu is this is a mule relative or
absolute reference okay and it's really
the difference if your trainee say and
the meal that's the difference here
right that appears in my number particle
so it's the difference of ESA from come
from a mule from si that is the chemical
potential okay
camel potential determine the number of
particles in the system okay so here
what I have is a messy mule messy you
say that's the separation of MU from
easy this one let's say okay I'm going
to do this this is my chemical potential
EF okay so now I have well understanding
is the where is a chemical potent you
can pause and here is the driving force
for mass diffusion mass transfer okay
the gridding and are a few other
quantities what's my electric field
right what's the F what's the force
acting on the particle electricity we
know the force is related to electric
field anybody remember basic relation
force the electric field times one Q
charge right if the Yi if the electron
is negative II then that that again I'm
just going to carry Q I assume a
positive charge because it's very
confusing right and then electrical
potential is relatable
you'll actually feel is related fear the
related potential right and that
potential Phi what is Phi anybody know
the name Oh put a you here this is your
electro static potential okay so you
have your actual static potential and uh
and then say the energy at the potential
energy that's where all those different
units all right the electrostatic
position is another energy unit put so
energy is aq times the phi e yo energy
of the charge the q times phi e this has
the unit as my e in the under diagram I
drew Phi e it is the electrostatic
potential okay and Q of course again say
if you take a Yi Q is negative Yi you
gather all this side problem you have to
take care of but the force is laid here
our potential data you all know it's a
very universal
right after the lignum of the real
potential another energy another
electrostatic potential okay so now with
this I'm going back I'm coming back to
here I'm going to do my gradient
so what I have here is say I consider a
conductor and I have current flow inside
and it's a semi conductor
I have the no core use it could vary and
in fact the þÿÿÿ will always be parallel
to EC okay you like to study potential
because the Q is the potential energy of
the charge right so potential energy I
say this is a the bottom of this the
where my electron potential energy is
right so I would say I can always think
that U is parallel to you say and now
I'm going to do say I also may have a
temperature gradient so the this could
be equal to have T is a function of X
and I have issei is a function of X okay
I have a meal as function of X I have
three okay but you see mule is my later
on us a mule under my relative say
absolute the references my
electrochemical potential is not just in
my chemical potential okay okay sorry I
have forgot another one my EF I just
mentioned right EF is the chemical
potential because here is mute mass this
is my FA yeah okay chemical danger is
driving the mass diffusion so now I'm
going to do my F zero I'm going to write
F zero equals x polish or ek minus EF
KBT
plus one okay this is under my new bill
master you see so that that my EF is
relative to the relative to the point of
the EC so now I'm going to do my ad my F
equals F zero months tau YX so my here I
have VX + DF 0 DX that's the first term
right the F 0 DX my second term is f the
force force will be then my kill charge
times here what I have is the electric
field is a negative electrical potential
gradient right or is the Q this is my
ESA so it's negative so what I have
maybe I do don't do kill I will do my
negative we say DX that's force is there
oh yeah I should have a liggett here in
the front right negative in the front
because it's a potential gradient forces
the potential negative up potential
credit okay so that's my force and the
DF 0 DP P is a momentum right here you
say my ek is a P squared over 2m right
is px square py square PZ square MVX mm
say right and we X so this is a force in
the X direction that means
guess why it should be TFS 0 DP X okay
so DF 0 TP X but the F 0 is not the
function px so this is the through ek
which is the final px so I use chain
rule again is d EK d EK d PX right okay
so d EK d PX o is a wat DK d PX so that
gave me just a px that's just the my X
right ok so this term is MV x & Dec DX
okay so here I will get another way X I
get another way X so I will have similar
way X but now DF 0 DX DF 0 DX DF is the
function of X T is the function of X
right so I'm going to write it in to so
so when I do DF 0 D X and now F is a
function of X but here I do DF 0 DK DK
so I see EF and the UK is just a change
in position negative positive sign right
so when I do my first term DF DX I have
to do partial write DF DF DF DF DX and
DF DT DT DX but I'm going to keep my
location simpler so I'll always convert
back into DF dek ok so I'm going to do
DF the first one is
d okay DF 0 DX is DF 0 D ek-
because here I'm really doing de f d so
de f D X that's the EF take care of my
years as a function of X okay my circle
time takes care of my T as a function of
X and then you do that
let me write this into in the in that
case what I write is again I write a D
because for my location DF 0 de que I
still want the UN though is DT but I
write a DK so the difference of the with
respect to D DT is e K mass EF KBT and I
have DT DX so so I'm writing this EF as
the function of X T as a function of X
that derivative we in two three two two
terms mathematically they are equivalent
because of this exponential function
okay one more step by our stop today I
have to finish this one okay so what I
am going to have then
I'm substituting in to all the three
terms now if I after I substitute into
all those three term what I will get is
F equals F zero plus how we ex and I
will have a de f DX plus de sá DX plus
ek minus EF and the KB T and DT DX and D
EF t fde K so this is the one I combine
this term with this term with this term
and write this term here I get my final
expression and one more step you can
take is this two together
DF D say you can say my mule the
chemical potential is the EC plus EF
that's a relative to adding horizontal
actual reference right this is the
electro relate to electrostatic
potential phi e this is related to the
chemical potential
so my mu is the electro chemical
potential here what I have here is the
electro chemical potential gradient and
here is temperature gradient so what you
are saying if I continue in the next
class I use this F I can calculate
current flux and you'll have the first
term is the electrochemical potential is
always the driving force over the
current flow you
measure you do not measure when you put
a voltage probe you do measure
electrostatic potential you measure
always the electrochemical potential
let's say what the book was commenting I
say ok and you do battery you deal with
the electrochemical potential you do
similar you do any set time you do like
it's electro chemical potential for the
current flow when they like to study
whether you can measure it actual study
put in sure in fact there are ways to
measure for example it's a it's
basically if you have PN Junction right
you have a semiconductor you have p-type
or n-type and there's potential
difference one way to measure is a user
a cantilever atomic force microscope
approach it and the electrostatic a
charge will actually expel this
differently but when you put the put
electrical lead there you always measure
it like to tell me about danger okay so
that's a the most time we're not careful
in talking about this and then you will
take you a long time to appreciate it
okay you're always a confuse me in the
sense that the charge is negative and
yeah okay I'll stop here